[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers
guten Abend in allen mit jedem neuen Tag
steigen die Opferzahlen die Russlands
Krieg fordert Leid und Tod in der
Ukraine mit jedem neuen Tag steigen auch
die Kosten die Weltbank schätzt dass der
Wiederaufbau des Landes mehr als 400
Milliarden Dollar verschlingen dürfte
mindestens die Zahl ist schwer fassbar
das ist fast so viel wie der Bund in
Deutschland im jährlichen Haushalt für
sämtliche seiner Ausgaben zur Verfügung
hat eine internationale Konferenz in
London soll Hilfe bringen und zwar
konkret und nicht nur als
Absichtserklärung dazu soll auch die
private Wirtschaft beitragen eine
gewaltige Anstrengung die am Ende den
Verursacher in Rechnung gestellt werden
sollen auch wenn alle einräumen dass der
Tag an dem Russland tatsächlich für
seine Zerstörungen zahlen könnte in
weiter Ferne liegt
was ganz akut und aktuell sichtbar ist
wie groß diese Verwüstungen sind und
welche Herausforderungen ganze Regionen
zu meistern haben neben dem täglichen
Beschuss
so sah es direkt nach der Zerstörung des
kachowka-staudamms in der Region Umkreis
Sonne aus und so eine Woche später erst
viel zu viel Wasser und dann viel zu
wenig beides ist ein Problem wie Alisa
jung berichtet
die Bibel stand das Wasser jetzt ist es
weg zwei Wochen nach der Zerstörung des
karofkadams wird das Ausmaß der
Katastrophe im Süden der Ukraine klar
nur Barf aus der penko Sucht in ihrem
Haus in Novo fast noch zu retten ist
die Wände sind kaputt
die Möbel sind nicht mehr zu benutzen
sie sind zerstört
alles werde ich nur noch als Brennholz
benutzen
[Musik]
erst kamen die Russen dann das Wasser
und spülte die Lebensgrundlage der
gesamten Gemeinde Weg luboff aus der
penko ist überzeugt die Zerstörung des
Staudamms ist ein Kriegsverbrechen
wir waren unter russischer Besatzung und
dann hatten sie bereits mit einer
Explosion gedroht aber sie lebten selbst
hier sie wussten vielleicht was die
Konsequenzen sein würden und als sie
sich zurückzogen taten sie es und
zerstörten damit die Ernte der Menschen
verseuchten ihre Trinkwasser Brunnen und
Böden unklar ob ihr Minen liegen und
wann die Gebiete wieder zu betreten sind
Wasser als Waffe am Stausee des
karofka-damms fehlt inzwischen so viel
dass hier in majanske kein Schiff mehr
anlegen kann an diesem Getreide Terminal
sollten jährlich 200.000 Tonnen übers
Wasser in die Welt transportiert werden
das wird nun Folgen haben
und das wird teurer für die
landwirtschaftlichen Erzeuger
das Unternehmen sollte Menschen aus drei
Verwaltungsbezirken Arbeit geben selbst
wenn sie das Getreide nun via Straße
transportieren würden russische Truppen
auf der anderen Uferseite haben sie hier
schon mehrfach beschossen 6 Sinus sind
nicht mehr zu benutzen wie ein
Sternenhimmel sieht es nun hier drinnen
aus Scherz zerrie Peter schewski
das ist die Zerstörung von allem damit
weder die landwirtschaftliche
Infrastruktur oder irgendeine andere
infrastrukturfunktionsfähig ist sie
zerstören alles damit wir hier so hart
wie möglich überleben es sei eine
künstlicher beigeführte Katastrophe sagt
Sie Peter schewski die die Ukraine nach
Kriegsende wohl noch lange beschäftigen
wird lubov aus der penko macht sich am
meisten Sorgen um die Zukunft ihrer vier
Enkel und die zerstörten Schulen
ich will dass unsere Kinder lernen und
eine Ausbildung erhalten es war unser
Traum das ganze Leben lang dass die
Kinder einen Beruf erlernen
ihren eigenen Traum vom bunten Häuschen
mit den Rosen will sie nicht aufgeben
sie wird Kraft finden es wird
weitergehen
der Leiter des Entwicklungsprogramms der
Vereinten Nationen war gerade selbst in
der Ukraine ist jetzt in London auf der
Geberkonferenz Achim Steiner guten Abend
guten Abend Herr Sievers was ist denn
ihr Eindruck herrschereimer Nägel mit
Köpfen oder wolkige Versprechungen bei
den unklar ist ob sie überhaupt gehalten
werden was wird daraus kommen in London
nein ich glaube es sind bereits sehr
viele Zusagen heute morgen rausgekommen
eine ganze Galerie von Außenministerin
und Premierministerin war hier
versammelt in der
Eröffnungsveranstaltung und viele
Zusagen wurden gemacht ich glaube die
Solidarität mit der Ukraine ist so stark
wie immer und was vor allem auch hier in
London im Vordergrund steht ist nicht
nur die humanitäre die Nothilfe die
militärische Hilfe sondern eben diese
Frage auch das wiederaufbauen einer
Wirtschaft eine Infrastruktur und genau
das glaube ich wird in den nächsten zwei
Tagen hier zentrales Thema sein Zusagen
alleine reicht denn das schon ist denn
in eine Zusage bereits konkrete Hilfe
denn hinter so einer Zusage kommt man ja
möglicherweise auch wieder zurück
zeigt die Vergangenheit zeigt die
Erfahrung leider
nun ich glaube die Voraussetzung ist
dass man erst einmal Finanzmittel hat um
überhaupt diese Art von
Wiederaufbauarbeit zu leisten meine
Reise in Ukraine der letzten Woche war
genau darauf abgezielt zu schauen was
funktioniert eigentlich wo wollen die
Ukraine die Priorität setzen welche
Programme haben wirklich eine
Auswirkungen allein das Beispiel
Wohneinheiten 1,5 Millionen Häuser
Apartments Wohnungen sind zerstört
worden wo sollen die Menschen wohnen
wenn wir nicht sofort wieder mit dem
Wiederaufbau dieser apartment-blocks
beginnen auch da hat die Ukraine selber
bereits Mittel zur Verfügung gestellt
das Entfernen von Landminen damit
Menschen mit der zurück auf den Acker
können und dort Getreide anzubauen und
das sind alles Beispiele die im
Augenblick absolute Priorität haben und
genau da ist internationale Gemeinschaft
natürlich sehr gefragt denn ohne Mittel
kann man diese Programme nicht
durchführen und wir sehen bereits dass
sie machbar sind und auch in einer
Größenordnung die wirklich verändert wir
sehen ein Land im Krieg aktuell wir
sehen aber auch immer wieder eine
Bevölkerung die die weitermachen
will und sofort wieder anpackt und wir
sehen mancherorts in der Ukraine fast
schon sowas wie Normalität wie viel
Wiederaufbau läuft denn bereits jetzt
während wir hier reden
sehr vieles ich habe in levif gesehen
wie in einem Krankenhauskomplex zum
Beispiel wie eine neue Plattform
geschaffen haben für Menschen Männer und
Frauen die letztlich Unternehmer sind
sie sind vertrieben aus dem Osten des
Landes Binnenflüchtlinge sie stehen vor
der Entscheidung geben wir ganz auf oder
fangen wir noch mal an wir haben
Programme inzwischen mit 20.000 kleinste
mittelunternehmen mit den mit kleinen
Cash grounds und Unterstützung und
Vernetzung und auch technischer Hilfe
wir bereits dabei sind wieder
Arbeitsplätze zu schaffen das ist das
Einkommen der Zukunft das ist auch die
Volkswirtschaft letztlich der Ukraine in
den nächsten Jahren millionen von
kleinstunternehmern Männern und Frauen
die diese Wirtschaft am Laufen halten
und diese Programme funktionieren
Infrastruktur beim Wiederaufbau von
Wohnungen in der Kiew im Vorort von
irpin schwer zerstört durch die Russen
habe ich selber sehen können wie wir
Appartements innerhalb weniger Monate
wieder aufbauen Menschen können wieder
nach Hause kommen und einziehen
Millionen von Menschen leben im
Augenblick als Binnenflüchtlinge bei
ihren Verwandten inzwischen Notlagern
genau hier kann man ansetzen
insgesamt stehen aber gewaltige Summen
im Raum die Weltbank spricht von über
400 Milliarden Euro die nötig werden für
den Wiederaufbau bei so gewaltigen
Summen ist natürlich auch die Gefahr
immer sehr groß was kann man denn tun
damit jetzt nicht die Korruption
angefeuert wird und sich einige Oli
gleichen was wir in der Vergangenheit ja
auch bereits gesehen haben
nun die Politik und auch die Wirtschaft
der Vergangenheit ist glaube ich
wirklich nicht mehr das was wir heute in
der Ukraine vorfinden es ist ein Land
mit in einem Krieg eine Regierung die
versucht ein Land am Laufen zu halten
wie sie schon sagten es ist eine
erstaunliche Normalität in der
Abnormalität dieser Situation man ist
auf den Straßen bis die sirenenstaaten
dann fliehen die Menschen von der Straße
kommen wieder raus vieles funktioniert
auch weiter genau das ist auch der
Ansatz unseres Entwicklungsprogramms der
Vereinten Nationen die Regierung dabei
zu unterstützen eine Volkswirtschaft am
Laufen zu halten und genau hier ist
natürlich gute Regierungsführung
Transparenz Integrität gefragt aber das
ist kein Disput auch die Ukraine hier
auf der Konferenz vom Präsidenten ist
über den Premierminister haben das
anerkannt und sie arbeiten an diesen
Systemen die lässt sich die Transparenz
schaffen um Vertrauen zu bilden sagt
Achim Steiner der Leiter des
Entwicklungsprogramms der Vereinten
Nationen herzlichen Dank für das
Gespräch ich danke Ihnen
und das haben wir aus Termin Gründen
heute Nachmittag aufgezeichnet so jetzt
Hanna du mit einem ersten Nachrichten
Überblick ja da schauen wir zuerst auf
eine umstrittene Entscheidung des
Bundeskabinetts das hat heute
beschlossen die bisher verbindlichen
sektorziele im Klimaschutzgesetz
abzuschaffen stattdessen sollen künftig
alle Bereiche zusammen ein Klimaziel
erreichen neu ist außerdem dass erst
dann Maßnahmen ergriffen werden müssen
wenn das Ziel zwei Jahre in Folge
verfehlt wurde wie genau und in welchem
Bereich das entscheidet die
Bundesregierung umweltverbände
kritisieren die Änderungen scharf sie
bemängeln eine eklatante Abschwächung
des bisherigen Gesetzes
und Klima und Umweltschutz ging es auch
bei einer weiteren Entscheidung des
Kabinetts beides soll künftig im
Straßenverkehr stärker berücksichtigt
werden dafür hat die Bundesregierung
eine Reform des Straßenverkehrsgesetzes
beschlossen die Kommunen sollen mehr
Spielraum erhalten zum Beispiel beim
Einrichten von Tempo 30 Zonen und für
das Ausweisen von sonderfahrspuren für
bestimmte klimafreundliche Fahrzeuge
das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat sich
heute mit dem Nachtragshaushalt 2021
beschäftigt und zwar mit der Frage ob
die Bundesregierung ungenutzte
corona-notkredite für den Klimaschutz
einsetzen darf konkret geht es um eine
Summe von 60 Milliarden Euro die
Unionsfraktion hatte geklagt sie sieht
in dem Vorgehen einen Verstoß gegen die
Schuldenbremse diese darf nur bei
außergewöhnlichen Notsituationen außer
Kraft gesetzt werden ein Urteil wird in
mehreren Monaten erwartet
der stellvertretende Vorsitzende der
FDP-Bundestagsfraktion Alexander Graf
lambsdorf soll noch in diesem Sommer
neuer deutscher Botschafter in Russland
werden das Auswärtige Amt erklärte dass
die Russische Föderation der Personal
jetzt zugestimmt und das sogenannte
agriment erteilt habe Lamsdorf folgt als
Botschafter auf Gesa Andreas von Geier
die Europäische Union verschärft ihre
Sanktionen gegen Russland das nun mehr
elfte Paket umfasst Maßnahmen gegen
weitere Personen und Organisationen
zudem sollen bestehende Schlupflöcher
geschlossen werden bisher wurden
bestimmte Sanktionen nämlich über
Drittstaaten umgangen nun soll es die
Möglichkeit geben ausgewählte Exporte in
bestimmte Drittländer einzuschränken die
Einigung muss noch von den EU-Staaten
angenommen werden das Geld als Formalia
im Zentrum von Paris hat es am
Nachmittag eine schwere Explosion
gegeben ein Gebäude stürzte teilweise
ein mehrere Häuser gerieten in Brand
nach Polizeiangaben wurden mindestens 24
Menschen verletzt vier davon schwer nach
weiteren Opfern wird gesucht die Ursache
für die Explosion ist noch nicht geklärt
vermutet wird ein Gasleck
in Deutschland hat der Staat das
Gewaltmonopol es gilt nicht das Recht
des Stärkeren selbst Justiz hat hier
keinen Platz dass man das überhaupt
betonen muss heute hat mit den
Geschehnissen in Nordrhein-Westfalen zu
tun wo es laut LKA mehr als 100
Großfamilien gibt mit zum Teil
kriminellen Strukturen die meisten haben
libanesische oder türkische Wurzeln die
Zahl der Straftaten die die Polizei
deren Mitgliedern anlastet geht in die
Tausende in der vergangenen Tagen
mussten die Beamten bei mehreren
Massenschlägereien einschreiten das
Thema beherrscht Schlagzeilen und
Gemüter und war heute auf der
Tagesordnung im Landtag Dominik
macht eure tiktok-apps zu und kommt mit
Blut trinken ruft ein Anführer den rund
200 libanesische stämmigen Männern zu
die durch die Essener Innenstadt ziehen
ihr Ziel ein syrisches Restaurant das
die vergangenen Freitag verwüsten und
dabei auch mehrere Menschen angreifen
bereits am Vortag prügeln im
benachbarten Castrop-Rauxel Libanesen
und Syrer aufeinander ein bewaffnet mit
Dachlatten und Messern
ein Syrer wird lebensgefährlich verletzt
und auch bei dem Überfall in Essen gibt
es Verletzte
Tage später zelebrieren solche Videos
den blutigen Aufmarsch von Libanesen in
Essen doch es gibt auch Menschen die
bereuen dass sie damit gemacht haben
berichtet Ahmad Omeirat er ist grüner
Stadtrat und hat selbst libanesische
Wurzeln der Streit habe sich in den
sozialen Medien aufgeschaukelt Ursprung
sei ein Konflikt zweier Großfamilien
ich denke die Auseinandersetzung dieser
Familienkonflikt hatte keinen
kriminellen Hintergrund ich denke die
Straftaten sind nachher eher über die
sozialen Medien entstanden mit
Beleidigungen und Bedrohungen was
passiert da gerade im Ruhrgebiet der
Migrationsforscher Ralf Kartbahn hat
ebenfalls libanesische Wurzeln er
beobachtet wie in den letzten Jahren
immer mehr syrische Großfamilien sich in
Essen angesiedelt haben und in
alteingesessenen Libanesen die Geschäfte
streitig machen legale wie Restaurants
und auch illegale wie Drogenhandel das
sei ebenfalls Hintergrund des Konflikts
den Zug käme das sowohl Essener Syrer
als auch Libanesen aus besonders
archaisch geprägten gegen den stammten
die Großfamilie stehe dort über allem
die kleine
Kriminalität
unterscheidet sich von der organisierte
Kriminalität der sie an Essen Stelle ein
integrations-problem ist das ist nicht
wie die Mafia oder ähnliche Universum
und
wir haben bis jetzt kein Konzept für die
Integration von hermetischen Gruppen die
sich selber von unserer Gesellschaft
abgrenzt für NRW ist Innenminister Royal
sind die Prügeleien ein besonderes
Ärgernis ist der Kampf gegen kriminelle
Clans doch so etwas wie sein
Markenzeichen und so wird er sich heute
im Landtag vehement gegen
Anschuldigungen zu wenig zu tun das
Gegenteil sei der Fall 30 Jahre lang hat
die Politik gepennt hat sich keiner
gekümmert wir sind jetzt seit fünf
Jahren dran wir kriegen Fortschritte hin
und zu sagen der jetzt nichts bewegt das
ist wirklich Quark die Ausschreitungen
nimmt die bundesinnenministerin heute
zum Anlass gemeinsam mit den Ländern
eine Allianz gegen Clan Kriminalität
bilden zu wollen auf allen Ebenen durch
Polizeipräsenz und der weitere Punkt ist
natürlich auch an die Strukturen zu
gehen zu sagen wo kriegen die
eigentliche Finanzierungen her was
müssen die offenlegen ich habe ja sehr
dafür geworben auch für ein Eigentums
und Wohnungsregister damit man auch
sieht wie sind tatsächlich
Eigentumsverhältnisse da brauchen wir
mehr Transparenz Enz in Deutschland
mittlerweile haben sich in einer Essener
Moschee klanführer zu einer Art
Friedensgipfel getroffen doch nicht alle
Familien waren dabei der Friede scheint
brüchig die Polizei hat angekündigt
wachsam zu sein damit sich solche Szenen
nicht wiederholen
im heute schon ein Update nachher Fragen
dazu an den zuständigen NRW
Innenminister wir haben ihnen gerade
kurz gesehen im Beitrag
angela Merkel ist Doktorin der Physik
sie ist auch Dr dr dr dr honores kausa
insgesamt 19 mal die 20 Ehrendoktor
würde folgt in einer Woche angela Merkel
ist außerdem Trägerin des spanischen
europapreises des freiheitsordens der
Ukraine und sie darf sich offiziell alte
Freundin des chinesischen Volkes nennen
da kommt eine ziemlich lange Liste
zusammen für eine Politikerin die immer
eher wenig Aufhebens um ihre Person
machen wollte und seit Merkel
Bundeskanzlerin ad ist und eine
Diskussion läuft um Entscheidungen und
Fehlentscheidungen in ihrer Amtszeit
wird diese Liste immer länger
das Großkreuz des Verdienstordens der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland in besonderer
Ausführung
der Staatspreis des Landes
Nordrhein-Westfalen und jetzt heute der
bayerische Verdienstorden aus der Hand
von Markus Söder da war doch was Stefan
Seifert
in Sachen Beziehungsstatus haben diese
beiden ja schon einiges durchlebt mit
dem Verhältnis von ehrendem und geehrter
fehlen Markus Söder und Angela Merkel
aber noch sichtbar Erfahrung wir ziehen
in die Mitte Kinder mit dem Hintergrund
der Ministerpräsident und CSU-Chef zieht
in Münchens Alter Königsresidenz heute
alle Register um die altkanzlerin und Ex
CDU-Chefin zu ehren
meine Damen und Herren auch ich wurde
gefragt warum den bayerischen
verdienstordnung Angela Merkel
eigentlich in einem Satz weil sie es
verdient hat Söder zeichnet das
Lebenswerk Merkels als Management der
vielen und schweren Krisen nach vor
allem in der Pandemie habe sich Merkel
um Bayern verdient gemacht
am Anfang fühlten die uns sehr allein du
Europa im Blick hast damals obwohl man
hätte sagen können naja vielleicht noch
einen eineinhalb Jahre Amtszeit das
lasse ich mal langsam angehen
positioniert und hast uns geholfen
und zwar mit vollsten Einsatz doch die
Ordensverleihung ist auch ein Dejavue
sie erinnert an die unionsdauer Schleife
aus Streit und Versöhnung mal roter
Teppich vor Prunk Kulisse mal Demütigung
auf offener parteitagsbühne in der
corona-krise wächst Söder gar an Merkel
wird fast Kanzlerkandidat in der
migrationskrise eskaliert der Streit bis
kurz vor Bruch
was aber zählt das waren immer zum Teil
nach langem Ringen gemeinsame Lösungen
Kompromisse die in den allermeisten
Fällen sowohl Deutschland als Ganzes als
auch Bayern gleichermaßen genutzt haben
deshalb war es immer spannend mit dem
Freistaat und mit der CSU
zusammenzuarbeiten langweilig war selten
Merkels Rede ist kurz und nüchtern geht
weit in die Geschichte zurück über ihre
Ära redet sie kaum den Gefallen die CSU
und ihr Personal zu loben tut sie Söder
nicht in den dank mischt sich fast
Verwunderung
und es war nicht nur mir nicht in die
Wiege gelegt diesen Verdienstorden zu
bekommen
sondern Bayern auch nicht in die Wiege
gelegt ausgerechnet Bundeskanzler einmal
mit diesem ordent
und dann ist dabei aller Feierlichkeit
noch der Elefant im Raum die
russland-politik dass der Grad bei
Merkel laudationen schmaler geworden ist
lässt Laudator Söder erkennen und ich
verstehe die Kritik und auch ich habe
mich jetzt im Nachhinein oft gefragt
hätte man nicht schon damals mit der
Besetzung der Krim alles anders machen
sollen hätte man nicht damals schon den
kompletten Bruch und die Isolation
Russlands voranbringen sollen
ich habe mir jetzt noch mal überlegt wie
war das eigentlich so um die Zeit 20 14
wie war eigentlich diese Situation
soweit ich mich erinnern kann gab es
ganz wenige die das damals so in der
Form gefordert haben
Merkel lässt heute beides an sich
abprallen die Kritik genauso wie das Lob
und so endet eine Feierstunde mit
zwischen Tönen Merkel und die CSU
bleiben sich heute ziemlich treu
[Musik]
so und jetzt hier noch mal Hannah mit
einer Nachricht die bahnfahrerin und
Bahnfahrer aufstrecken dürfte das kann
man so sagen die Tarifverhandlungen
zwischen der Deutschen Bahn und der
Eisenbahn und Verkehrsgewerkschaft EVG
sind gescheitert das hat die EVG am
Abend mitgeteilt die angebotene
Lohnerhöhung sei zu niedrig die Laufzeit
des neuen Vertrags von 27 Monaten zu
lang morgen will der Bundesvorstand der
EVG über das weitere Vorgehen
entscheiden möglich wäre ein
unbefristeter Streik
nach den deutsch-chinesischen
Regierungskonsultationen ist Chinas
Ministerpräsident Lee weiter nach Bayern
gereist und besuchte dort heute BMW und
Siemens die Volksrepublik ist ein
wichtiger Handelspartner allerdings
Stefanie Barrett das Land verliert an
Attraktivität für viele europäische
Unternehmen das zeigt jetzt eine Umfrage
ja eine Umfrage der Europäischen
Handelskammer in Peking bei Unternehmen
lässt aufhorchen denn nicht nur die
geopolitischen Risiken nehmen zu nach
der corona-krise will auch das
Wirtschaftswachstum in China nicht so
recht anspringen weshalb
unternehmensschefs das reicht der Mitte
inzwischen als größeres konjunkturrisiko
einstufen mit entsprechenden
Konsequenzen 10% haben bereits ihr Asien
Hauptquartier aus China verlegt
bevorzugt Richtung Singapur oder
Malaysia mehr als die Hälfte der
befragten Unternehmen beklagen fehlenden
fairen Wettbewerb Beschränkungen durch
Behörden so wie erzwungene Offenlegung
von Firmen Know-how diese Faktoren
sorgen ganz offenbar dafür dass die
Volksrepublik nicht nur für ausländische
Unternehmen an Attraktivität verliert
auch chinesische Kunden und Zulieferer
verlagern Investitionen ins Ausland
dennoch dann heute die Treffen in Bayern
mit BMW und Siemens wie ist das
einzuordnen ja das Treffen fand heute
auf Wunsch der chinesischen Delegation
statt aber es hat sich auch etwas
grundlegend verändert von sonst üblichen
neuen Milliarden schweren
Wirtschaftsabkommen ist anders als vor
fünf Jahren noch keine Rede mehr das
ganze wird mit
Kooperationsvereinbarungen wesentlich
kleiner gefahren aber china ist für die
deutschen Autobauer natürlich immer noch
der wichtigste Absatzmarkt der Welt
deshalb ist das Bemühen groß solange wie
es geht in diesem Geschäft zu bleiben
denn ob die deutschen Hersteller die
Aufholjagd bei der Elektromobilität in
China gewinnen können jetzt wo China
auch mit voller Kraft und finanziellen
Anreizen auf die Immobilität setzt das
ist längst nicht ausgemacht vielen Dank
Stefanie für diese Einschätzungen
und jetzt der Blick auf die Lottozahlen
an diesem Mittwoch die lauten 6 12 19 22
43 47 Superzahl 6 alle Angaben wie immer
ohne Gewähr
zum Fußball und damit zur deutschen
Nationalmannschaft die gestern Null zu
zwei gegen Kolumbien verloren hat es ist
das vierte Testspiel in Folge ohne einen
Sieg die DFB-Elf steckt in der Krise und
mit ihr Bundestrainer Hansi Fleck
die Startelf in Gelsenkirchen hat in
sich geballte Champions League Erfahrung
doch sie gehen wieder als Verlierer vom
Platz ein Rätsel als deutscher
Nationalspieler hast du eine gewisse
Verantwortung und du kannst mit dem was
gerade passiert überhaupt nicht
einverstanden sein der Bundestrainer ist
gefragt steht aber selbst in Frage der
DFB will an ihm festhalten trotzdem
misslungenen Testspiel Experimente wir
mal probiert wir haben was versucht und
es ging die Hose und so ist natürlich
kein Trost auch für die Fans für Fußball
Deutschland weil wir sind die
Nationalmannschaft und wir müssen uns da
anders präsentieren 02 gegen Kolumbien
ein Jahr vor der EM im eigenen Land und
ein halbes Jahr nach dem frühen Aus bei
der WM in Katar ist die
Nationalmannschaft nicht weitergekommen
Klopfgeräusche unter Wasser das ist ein
Zeichen an das sich alle Klammern müssen
denn es ist das bisher einzige mögliche
Zeichen von dem im Nordatlantik
vermissten Mini-U-Boot die Suche geht
weiter mit einem kleinen bisschen neuer
Hoffnung in einem Gebiet rund um die
Stelle an der die Titanic auf dem
Meeresboden liegt es ist ein Gebiet das
größer ist als Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
und die Zeit drängt der Sauerstoff für
die fünf Menschen an Bord des U-Boots
dürfte nicht einmal mehr für 24 Stunden
reichen wenn ihr mir Daniel
das Ticken der Zeit raubt Hoffnung dass
ticken unter Wasser hingegen spendet sie
es ist kurz nach Mitternacht Ostküsten
Zeit als die Sonare der Küstenwache ein
Geräusch wahrnehmen beschrieben wird es
als klopfen oder ticken das letzte Mal
war es vor gut zwei Stunden zu hören und
so gibt es zumindest einen kleinen
Anlass daran zu glauben dass die fünf
U-Boot Insassen irgendwo da unten doch
noch am Leben sind
extrem schwer zu sagen was die Quelle
dieser Geräusche ist unser Team setzt
zahlreiche Sensoren ein und sendet die
Daten so schnell es geht zu den besten
Analytikern der Welt
dieser wiederum schicken ihre Auswertung
zurück zu unserem Team und wir treffen
daraufhin unsere weiteren Entscheidungen
sollten die fünf Passagiere noch am
Leben sein kann man sich kaum vorstellen
welchen Albtraum sie gerade durchleben
mit jeder verstrichenen Stunde wird die
Situation beklemmender die
Rettungskräfte tun alles was in ihrer
Macht steht um den vielen
Herausforderungen her zu werden sie
suchen ein rund 20.000 Quadratkilometern
großes Gebiet ab zudem herrscht in der
Tiefe des Atlantiks enorme Druck es ist
stockfinster der beste Freund eines
französischen titanic-experten der an
Bord ist meldet sich heute zu Wort
gemeinsam hätten sie die Firma auch
schon Geld schon seit langem vor
möglichen Komplikationen gewannt wir
hatten uns schon gedacht dass so etwas
irgendwann mal passieren wird wir haben
die potentiellen Schwierigkeiten mit den
Verantwortlichen diskutiert also was tut
man wenn sich das U-Boot am Titanic
fragt wenn die Batterien versagen wenn
sie nicht mehr aufsteigen können oder
was auch immer aber niemand hat etwas
getan
als die Titanic 1912 sank riss sie rund
1500 Menschen mit in den Tod
ein gutes Jahrhundert später Bank die
Welt das an dieser Stelle im Atlantik
nicht noch weitere fünf Menschen ihren
Abenteuergeist mit dem Leben bezahlen
die Titanic galt damals als unsinkbar
sie war es nicht beim Mini-U-Boot der
Abenteurer gab es ganz offenbar schon
länger Zweifel an der Sicherheit die
Passagiere haben gewusst dass sie sich
auf einen Wagnis einlassen es bleibt
ihnen und allen anderen die mit Bangen
die Hoffnung auf ein Wunder
was hier bei uns in Europa auf dem
Mittelmeer passiert muss uns ebenfalls
weiterhin beschäftigen die Zahl der
Flüchtlinge die den gefährlichen Weg
über das Meer suchen steigt stetig das
auslandsjournal jetzt gleich im
Anschluss ist unterwegs mit der
tunesischen Küstenwache und online das
ist ebenfalls ein echter reinguckt Tipp
die reise-doku von Nina lieber geil und
Sebastian eben durch die Länder der
ehemaligen Sowjetunion Leben im Schatten
Russlands 0:45 Uhr hier im ZDF Fernsehen
oder ab sofort in der ZDF Mediathek
ganze Reihe von Tipps heute
um 0 Uhr 30 gibt's nämlich unser heute
journal Abteil direkt davor und zwar
moderiert von Christopher Wehrmann so
von uns war es aber vom gesamten Team
ein angenehmer
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter eine kritische
Wetterlage stellt sich morgen im
Tagesverlauf ein wir haben es mit einem
tief zu tun das nähert sich bringt
feuchte und heiße Luftmassen mit dieses
Tief hört auf den Namen Lambert und
bringt teilweise Regenmengen von 60 bis
90 Liter auf den Quadratmeter in kurzer
Zeit in der Spitze das ist gut möglich
teilweise auch Hagel 5 bis 7 cm
Korngröße das sind die größten Körner
sozusagen und dazu auch Organ bin bis
130 km pro Stunde und sogar Tornados
vereinzelt sind möglich schauen uns die
Details an in der Nacht kommt von
Südwesten schon die Gewitter auf die
sind schon teilweise im unwetterbereich
ganz im Osten ist es aber trocken und
morgen am Vormittag den sich diese
Gewitter weiter Richtung
Nordrhein-Westfalen und Hessen aus dann
spielt tatsächlich Starkregen eine Rolle
aber Hagel und Sturm teils Orkanböen
sind auch möglich im Osten und im
Südosten erst einmal trocken zum
Nachmittag und Abend geht es dann im
Osten und im Süden zur Sache teilweise
eben diese heftigen Gewitter diese
hochreichenden Gewitterwolken mit
Starkregen Hagel und orkanböden ja und
ganz im Norden da bleibt es trocken
Temperaturen dazu 35 Grad im Südosten
Deutschlands hier lädt sich die Luft
noch mal ordentlich auf mit Energie ganz
im Westen 22 Grad schon deutlich kühler
und die nächsten Tage ja die beruhigen
sich allmählich der Regen wird weniger
20 bis 27 am Freitag und das Wochenende
ist komplett trocken ein schöner Abend